as you point out in your book you carry
on about share
and I mean it is kind of mind-blowing
for a kid from Saint Louis right yes yes
Whoever thought I mean Cher is one of
the biggest stars in the world I mean
without doubt super talented woman I
mean great actress great singer she's
gorgeous she shared yeah as you write
like oh my God Cher is trying to track
down Anderson Cooper and she thinks to
call you right right it's it's sort of
mind-blowing it's mind-blowing It's
mind-blowing to me listen I think the
book is a snapshot of being a single dad
but it's also a snapshot of pop culture
in the year 2022 and you know all the
names are names that are coming in and
out of my show or or my life or the news
or whatever and so yes when Cher texts
me I am blown away and I definitely
that's going in the book here is the
entry from your Journal during the show
I missed a call from Cher Cher was
looking for Anderson wondering if a
French lady answered his phone I texted
her his number did I ever think Cher
would call my phone looking for someone
yes it's definitely not calling to talk
to me she's I mean she thinks Anderson
is the Hat there's the two ACS and I'm
the devil and he's the saint it's like
Goofus and Gallant if you remember I
sure do Highlights Highlights yeah yeah
Cher called Anderson during a commercial
break to tell him he's doing a great job
that blew me away I don't know that says
a lot to me about Cher that she would
call Anderson Cooper up during his
broadcast to say how great he's doing
that you know what people don't do that
I know I know they don't yeah I mean
that's a sweet thing for her to do I
agree and he was in the Ukraine at the
time I believe literally wow yeah
Anderson's a little bit crazy right the
way he loves to go to dangerous places
don't you think he should stop now that
he has children I'm kind of used to him
flitting around the world to these
horrible things but when he left for
that one I was like dude you have two
kids like
you know it's it's scary as a friend
foreign